[Music]
breaking bread with the enemy is
something I mean literally
not if you're gluten intolerant but if
you're not literally having food with
people who are on the other side of an
issue often allows you to go back to a
very early thing that developed in us as
we evolved and that was the idea of
sharing resources creates connections
between us it allows us to begin to
understand where other people are coming
from it allows us to have more charity
in ourselves with regard to
understanding their point of view and I
think all in all it leads to a situation
where you have better outcomes it's not
always the case this can go too far as
when politicians spend time with
particular lobbyists and special
interest groups and end up shifting not
based on rationality and not based on
justice but shifting basically on
loyalty of who they hang out with but I
do recommend to a lot of activists that
they try to literally sit down at a
table with somebody who is the enemy and
see if they can have a conversation and
preferably to do it over food or drink
because there is something very primal
in us about sharing food and drink that
allows us I think to open our hearts and
our minds if the tools you're using to
do activism are tools that can be used
in highly destructive ways I often
recommend to people I think carefully
about deploying those tools we don't
want an arms race and activism we don't
want a situation for example which has
happened in many cases where people go
after people's families or children in
terms of social media attacks where they
do things that are just out of line make
false charges against people if you're
using those kinds of tools those are the
kinds of tools that then become ever
more common in our society and it
doesn't help anybody so I try to
encourage people who do activism to
think really carefully about whatever
you're doing would you want it to be
done to you is it something that has
integrity is it something that will
maintain your integrity and are you not
creating an arms race because an arms
race isn't going to help anybody
it may sound really strange to say to an
activist that a way to be a good
activist is to take time to be
nonpartisan because by definition
activism is partisan and yet I think
it's really important
valuable to step back when possible and
try to spend a little time doing
descriptive research not normative
research that says this is good this is
bad this is true this is false but
rather trying to do descriptive work
that simply understands what's happening
in the world one value of that is it
gets you knowledge that is useful in
terms of understanding how to achieve
your goals but another reason that is
super useful is because it actually
reminds you of what the other side may
be seeing that you may be missing
because you're blinded by your partisan
side so it allows you to step back and
say to yourself okay what other points
of view might there be here what other
knowledge might there be that I'm
missing
I run a non-partisan a local newspaper
that I founded for my city because we
were living in what's called a news
desert which means the internet
basically had crushed the economy of
local news where I live which is East
Lansing Michigan and I was really
concerned that the people of East
Lansing had no idea what was going on at
City Council at Planning Commission they
would just see buildings go up and would
be upset about it but have no idea it
was even coming they didn't know we had
a two hundred million dollar debt
happening even that we have only 20,000
permanent residents so it's an enormous
debt for our city they just didn't know
what's going on and so when I founded
that newspaper I realized it needed to
be nonpartisan so that people could feel
there was a place they could come and
get reliable knowledge and that that was
pre Trump I mean this was already a
problem happening in the mid 2010s this
was 2014 when I started it and one of
the things I've learned from doing that
is when I have to do nonpartisan news
reporting it really forces me to step
back and say to myself okay who might
have a point of view that I haven't
thought about and I've got to go out and
listen to people I wouldn't normally
listen to I have to go and seek answers
to questions I have to fact-check myself
so my assumption that X is true well
maybe X isn't true and I have to go and
look at the facts and that really
changes how we are all thinking about
something but engaging people in the
nonpartisan process I use citizen
journalists I've really found that it
helps them understand that they may not
know everything it breeds a kind of
humility it breeds a desire for more
knowledge and interestingly it breeds a
kind of political sympathy where even if
they don't change their mind personally
but they're doing the non part
and reporting their understanding much
better what somebody on the other side
is seeing and that's extraordinary I
mean I never would have occurred to me
that spending time in non-partisanship
smake you a more sympathetic person but
that often happens
[Music]